california firefighters are on high
alert for more wildfires this morning
as parts of the state remain under a
critical red flag warning
the bond fire which started last week
has destroyed at least
30 structures it was spotted by a remote
camera network that firefighters used to
locate wildfires
and dispatch crews you can see the fire
growing in this time lapse video carter
evans
shows how the cameras are making a big
difference
the massive wildfires that have torn
through california
burned with an intensity few have seen
before
entire towns overrun by flames
moving at unprecedented speeds and
some barely made it out alive every fire
that starts has this potential to grow
like we've never seen it grow before
now firefighters like cal fire san diego
unit chief tony meacham
are increasingly turning to a statewide
network of nearly 650 fire cameras
as soon as a flare-up is spotted
firefighters remotely control
nearby cameras to triangulate its
location when you pinpoint with the
cameras where a fire is
how quickly are you acting on that
versus without the camera
the things that our fire ground
commanders do on the ground that used to
take us 20 30 minutes to get to the fire
and make those decisions now we're doing
within seconds
how much of a difference does those
first few minutes make i can't even put
it into words
our dispatchers will start moving
additional resources towards a fire
before the first fire engines are even
on scene asking for that
what we've done is we've built the
modern day fire tower
geologist neil driscoll is part of the
non-profit alert wildfire
he proposed adding the cameras to a
network of remote seismic stations
after a close call at his own home he
took us to see one high atop palomar
mountain in san diego county
at the site of a nearly 100 year old
fire tower
on a clear day like this they can see on
the order of about 70 miles
at night using the near infrared they
can see about 100 to 120 miles
when the lilac fire exploded in san
diego in 2017
commanders were able to watch the
fast-moving flames on the cameras
and quickly determined the engines they
dispatched would not be enough
we doubled the initial response that we
sent so we had over
40 fire engines going to the lilac fire
within the first 10 minutes before units
were even on scene
did that save lives do you think i think
it absolutely did
went towards me each camera station is
self-sufficient with solar and battery
backups and a microwave link transmits
the live images which anyone can watch
online
along with firefighters what's it like
to watch the fire approaching one of
these cameras
you know it's a little scary the lake
napa lightning fire burned right into
the camera and then the image froze of
that just orange sky around the camera
in the middle of the day
each camera station can cost up to 40
thousand dollars
often paid for by funding from the state
and local utilities
a small price according to chief meacham
when we measure the cost of wildland
fires now we're measuring in the
millions of dollars
per day to suppress a fire so you know a
30 or 40 thousand dollar camera that can
allow us to allocate resources put that
fire out
quicker in the long run i think we're
saving the state money through the
camera network
for cbs this morning carter evans san
diego
thank you carter evans 40 thousand
dollars not chump change but it's
certainly money well spent when you see
the results